TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
The Developer Show.
Today, we're at Flutter
Live, taking place
at the Science Museum in London.
Now, if you didn't
already know, Flutter
is Google's UI
toolkit for creating
fast and beautiful native
apps for iOS and Android
from a single code base.
The full keynote
is linked below.
But if you just
want the highlights,
here they are: the
Flutter Live Top Five.
Number one on today's list
is Flutter version 1.0.
See what I did there?
As we heard in
the keynote, there
are developers around the
world, shipping apps written
with Flutter to hundreds
of millions of users.
So the primary focus
of this release
is bug fixes and stabilization.
But it also includes a few
new things, like Dart 2.1
and previews for Add to
App and Platform Views.
The number two slot goes to
Square for their new Flutter
SDKs.
Now, they're making it easy
to accept payments for goods
and services with Flutter, both
in person with a Square payment
reader, as well as from
inside your mobile app.
Number three is Flare.
Two Dimensions
launched Flare today.
It's a tool that allows you to
create vector animations that
can be embedded into an existing
Flutter app as a widget.
It's a really tight
integration that
supports ongoing collaboration
between designers
and developers throughout
the build process.
Number four is codeMagic.
It's made by Nevercode, and
they make continuous integration
and continuous delivery
tooling for mobile apps.
With codeMagic, you can select
a GitHub repo with a Flutter
project and quickly
create continuous
build flows that runs tests and
generates binary app bundles
that you can upload
directly to the Apple App
Store and the Google Play Store.
OK, number five.
We'll end our list
with Hummingbird.
This is an experimental,
web-based implementation
of the Flutter runtime,
which is really cool when
you think about it.
You can write your app
in Dart, and in addition
to compiling to
date of arm code,
you can also target
JavaScript, which
enables your Flutter code to
run on the standards-based web.
Well, that's it: your
Flutter Live Top Five.
For all the announcements
and updates,
click the links in
the description below.
And on your way there, take
a moment to share this video
with your friends.
They'll thank you for
it, and we'll thank you
by doing more of them.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
The Developer Show,
and I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]